[Music]
it's been a crazy week in america
let's find out what happened
president biden's new jobs and
infrastructure proposal
reportedly includes free community
college universal pre-k
and a national paid leave program or as
fox news reported it they're going to
give immigrants your guns
sean hannity doesn't sound like that but
he looks like he sounds like that yeah
he sounds like that in his head
yeah that's how he thinks he sounds yeah
poor thing
yeah queen elizabeth ii sent a note on
monday to a hospital that recently
treated her husband
prince philip it said are you sure
he's alive
[Music]
i mean technically that's a pulse we
gotta let him out of here
dude have you heard of the undead
yeah yes set up telling me my brain
looks delicious sir i'm trying to help
you scrumptious
fancy ass mummy yeah people in britain
last year bought 86 million pounds worth
of vinyl records
and when i heard that i was like
nice that is a true delight
that is a gem sorry can we is there a
way to cut to tarik right now tarek you
got to try this you're going to love it
you're going to love it okay all right
i'm gonna give it a shot wait
what
[Laughter]
oh yeah wait can i try one more time
yeah sure all right
like i was gonna rip my pants
[Applause]
doesn't always work
[Laughter]
his pants are made of records
you guys you're never gonna believe this
starbucks announced
this week that by the year 2030 they
will cut their water usage in half
which explains their new drink starbucks
just the beans
the creators of sesame street introduced
two new black muppets this week to help
facilitate discussions of racism and
black identity
which must have been a bummer for the
new black muppets
can we just do counting oh oh
re relive the drama all right
s is for systemic racism
come to think of it this was a white man
holding my hand
what [ __ ] is this
yes
oh my gosh everyone in here is horrible
[Laughter]
you guys a tennessee man over the
weekend lost a lottery ticket
worth one million dollars but then found
it again
in the parking lot of an auto parts
store to celebrate
he's taking his wife to napa
you thought it was going to be wine but
no no it's car parts
yeah yep the director of the film
mrs doubtfire recently confirmed the
existence of an
r-rated version of the movie it's called
oh my dad was mrs mother
doubtfire
that's the only change that's the only
change yeah
they don't cuss in the movie or anything
but that is the title yeah
and finally pharmaceutical company
pfizer this week said
it is testing an antiviral coronavirus
drug
that is taken orally it will be made
available the day after you get your
second
shot and that was the monologue
derek did you like the monologue i did
hey tarik what do you got there oh just
a bowl of my favorite cereal
cinnamon toast crunch derek
wow
some guy found shrimp in his cinnamon
toast crunch this week
what this week a guy in california found
actual shrimp in a box of cinnamon toast
crunch
ew for real yes
jesus that was a close one it really was
good thing i brought a backup snack
[Music]
okay that's it no more snacks for you
yeah
i lost my appetite now we've covered a
lot of news so far tonight but
there's one more thing i'd like to talk
about you've probably seen a lot of
stories in the news lately regarding
attacks on asian americans stories like
this one
car ramming at rally protesting
anti-asian hate
being investigated as hate crime that's
right
they're not sure if it's a hate crime so
they're going to investigate now we here
at the
amber ruffin show respect the due
process
of an investigation because there's
nothing more dangerous than jumping
to conclusions so i'd like to help them
out no not that
yes i'd like to help them out with this
investigation
i'd like to examine the facts of the
case and use deductive reasoning to
figure out once and for all
whether or not this is a hate crime
okay let's see
oh it says here
car ramming at a rally protesting
anti-asian hate
[Music]
hmm
investigation over it's a hate crime
now now detective ruffin
i believe a second opinion is an order
you're bringing too much emotion into
this and i'd like to take or look at
this article and see if i
from a clear-headed perspective might
come to a
new conclusion yeah no
so the man yelled racial epithets as he
rammed his car
through the pedestrian route
[Music]
hmm
it's a hate crime i'm disappointed in
you two
so quick to throw out the wide world of
possibilities that exist
beyond this room i guess that's why i've
been called in
for a third opinion to examine the
alternatives
and think outside the box
it says the sheriff's office
identified the suspect as a white male
in his 50s
oh yeah that's a classic hate crime so
what do we do now i don't know we
blacked out like three whole minutes for
this segment
hey did y'all see one division no was it
good
oh oh i was going to ask you i haven't
seen it either oh
this hat is itchy i have my own youtube
channel now
yay be sure to subscribe for a lot of
show clips and a lot of digital
exclusives
and a lot of this